It's just after 5:30 am when I roll out of
bed and start walking around the streets of
Jaffna.
Beach Road is quietly waking up, a lady is
sweeping on the side of the road, a few people
are washing their clothes, and motorcycles
randomly breeze past.
The air is already warm and humidity is already
intense.
Luckily not all of Jaffna is still quiet.
I'm heading on over to grab some local style
breakfast and a few cups of tea.
Ok, I'm about to chow down on some local breakfast.
Paratha which is - oh the power has gown out
now, but anyways.
A piece of warm paratha bread is like a roti,
and dip it into coconut sambal which is coconut
mixed with chil.
Sorry, the power has gone out guys, but I'm
going to keep on munching!
Mmmm, so good, coconut with chili and lime.
I've also got some curry sauce to dip it into.
Ohh that's insane.
Aww, dude that curry sauce is bomb.
Washing it down with tea, Wow!
After breakfast, life in Jaffna has begun.
I might go check out this Fort right here.
Just a few years ago, Jaffna was a war zone.
As you can see there's all kinds of bombed
out structures and old homes.
Now that the vegetation has grown up over
the ruins, this type of scenery is really
common here in Jaffna.
Right now it's about 9 am, but the sun is
just absolutely blazing hot.
I can't even, you got to cover up your head
or you're just going to dehydrate within moments.
From the bombarded neighborhoods, it's just
a short 5 minute walk to the bustling center
of Jaffna town.
Over here they are filling up buses.
Filling them to capacity, stuffing people
in like sardines, but I'm going to choose
the walking option right now, straight through
the center of town.
Alright, I just picked up a snack, a mango,
chopped up like this.
Let me grab a chunk.
It's sour!
It's real sour, ok that's a bit too sour for
me.
Nallur Kovil is the most famous Hindu temple
in Jaffna.
Traditional ceremonies are held everyday.
I arrived just in time for the 4 pm session.
And to enter you have to take off your shirt,
so I'm going to quickly take off my shirt,
but unfortunately photography is strictly
prohibited inside, so you're not going to
see more of this temple, but I'm going to
go in and catch a ceremony.
They have ceremonies throughout the day, I'm
at the 4 o'clock session.
So if you come to Jaffna, you got to check
out Nallur Kovil.
I'm at a restaurant called Hotel Rolex, about
the smash down on some awesome looking food.
I got a paratha, and this is actually a squid,
a local squid curry.
Grab a piece of the squid.
Get a bit of the rice and chilies and tomatoes.
That squid curry is awesome!
I also got daal and rice, anyway, I'm going
to dig into the food, it's too good.
One thing you'll need to get used to when
you come to Sri Lanka is the napkins, made
from yesterday's newspaper.
Alright, see you guys later, I'm about to
devour this food.
My last tasty treat of the day is something
that's very dear to Sri Lankan's.
I'm about to taste for the first time, something
called wood apple juice, made from the bizarre
wood apple fruit.
It's pretty brown looking.
Take a tamarind fruit and cross it with blue
cheese, and you have wood apple juice.
It's rather bizarre, but, it's pretty good.